this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and this is a
cosmic queries edition
that's what becoming a fan favorite and
when I do cosmic queries you know Chuck
nice can't be far behind Chuck hey hey
what's happening the owners welcome back
in that yeah yeah yeah well yeah
virtually there it's in the in the in
the corona verse house
that's right you all had the same Corona
verse house right today we're doing
cosmic queries on algorithms and data
algorithms and data love me some
algorithms and data cuz they had nothing
happened I do not I'm not a big fan not
a fan of either I mean I'm a fan of data
both both the actual information kind
and the Android from Star Trek I'm a bet
fan of data algorithms yeah I forgot we
had a whole whole entity named data and
Android basically yeah yeah so what we
have here is we've invited into studio
today we have an expert on algorithms
and data the mathematician Hanna Frey
who's dialing in from the UK Hanna
welcome thank you very much hey Chuck
you're not the only person who hates the
word algorithm conference this guy thing
like I think is a word that makes about
85% of people want to gouge out their
own eyes yeah but it does make the
remaining 50% of people mildly aroused
well you know yeah male aroused breast
because al is only mildly sexy mr. mr.
go rhythm exactly
so did we get your full bio here your
associate professor of mathematics
University College London and you
co-host a BBC radio show radio for
because Radio BC has very
stove-piped channels and it's the
curious cases of Rutherford and Frey
yeah now you have to do some splainin on
that one author of the book recently
released left just last year hello world
being human in the age of algorithms so
you have the person for this for this
cosmic queries just Hannah if I may can
I just make you feel a little more at
home digitally as we cross the Great
Pond there we go here we go
Oh BBC news time five o'clock GMT the
Brits show off that they have the Prime
Meridian
so yes exactly Universal Time Greenwich
means and it's me I live in Greenwich
the Prime Meridian is about 100 metres
from my house oh do you feel it what's
quite knows are you going for like there
you go for a little walk around this
like a peninsula and along the Prime
Meridian as it goes across the water
there's just an arrow that says here oh
no I forgot mr. conference of the earth
now sixteen thousand kilometres no no
I'm Way bigger than that yeah people
once thought it was sixteen thousand in
ancient Greece so we got an update she's
a fan of history that's not which I
quite like we're about 50 thousand
kilometres 40 to 50 thousand kilometres
yeah right Wow
I know it two miles and you the guys who
gave us miles so it's twenty-five
thousand miles is what that is but I'm
just delighted you live near the Prime
Meridian and you can get a little vibe
from it when when you walk so tell me
tell me about data what's the state of
data today relative to like when any of
us were kids or even before they were
computers there were data of course
predates computers so
what's going on today well in some ways
I mean in a lot of ways not that much
has changed I mean it's still a case of
you know people collecting statistics
about humans about how we behave about
what we do using kind of mathematical
techniques to analyze it and trying to
infer scientifically everything that you
can about our behavior from it so you
know this is like a subject that has a
long history going back to the fifties
or sixties I think that what's really
changed is just the volume of data I
mean you don't need me to tell you just
that the incredible amounts of data that
has collected on us but I think for me
it's not just the amount of data that's
that's directly collated about us is
there things that you can infer from
that data and sort of the guess is that
you could make about people that you
wouldn't necessarily realize that you
could do so a really messes up words um
what I'm talking about here is I was
talking to a chief data officer for
supermarkets as chain of supermarkets in
the UK and the supermarket they they
have access to everything that everyone
buys so they know what's in your basket
they know your weekly shop but they also
sell home insurance right so they can
tell who makes them you know higher
claims and their home insurance and
compare it to what people are buying and
they realized in their data that you can
you can tell that people who claim less
on the home insurance of people who tend
to cook food at home which is kind of
like okay I mean why don't you here is I
will that sort of make sense again so
right if you're very house proud person
and you're spending ages creating a meal
from scratch then you know you're not
gonna let your kids play football in the
house right so I kind of the groups
connect but the question is how do you
decide who's a home cook anyway it turns
out that there is one item that's like
the strongest indicator of all this this
one item that's in your basket that's
the biggest giveaway that you are a home
cook more than any other I guess - I
guess now let me see I like to cook at
home and we see I cook a certain
but I can't cook without olive oil mmm
anchovy paste oh yeah I think it'll pay
something that's so base level kitchen
preparation so it's a little bit more
little bit more I guess of oh it's fresh
fennel it's fresh and I think that's
right like you just wouldn't if you're
buying fresh fennel you know you're only
cooking at home that is the only purpose
for freshmen I mean seriously if
nobody's saying like oh I have to pick
up some fresh fennel I need to shine my
shoes oh yeah so I started buying fresh
fennel to see if my high mature yet so
so that's one thing where the access
people have to who and what you are when
it's becomes when the data is consumer
based data so I guess we get that and a
lot of people are fear that or angered
by it but before we land there more
securely let me just comment that as the
volume of data has grown because
computers are obtaining data constantly
hasn't the computing ability to analyze
data risen with it so that we're not
really feeling the stress of being
smothered and data that we might have
feared a few decades ago yeah well as
honest you mean we don't think that the
Faris month so I first heard from John
Allen Paulus now this is now mid 90s
late 90s what he said was the Internet
is the world's biggest library the
problem is all the books are scattered
on the floor and I said well there's a
brilliant analogy but at the time there
wasn't a Google search engine or any
kind of way to organize that information
within a few years they were search
engines so the books were no longer on
the floor who knows where the hell they
are now but they're not on the floor so
yeah it was clever but it doesn't apply
today because we can get through the
data and my people we have very big
telescopes getting a lot of data on the
universe
half of the effort in prepping for that
telescope is the data pipeline to handle
the data so are you can you say that
you're awash in data are you are you on
top of the situation well okay okay so
definitely like the amount of grunt that
you have now just the I mean you just
didn't have access to before you can
handle you can handle vast assets with
just incredibly intricate detail about
you know everything from the cosmos to
human behavior that you just weren't
able to before but the thing is is that
I think the biggest challenge when it
comes to data isn't so much about volume
but more about quality and thing is that
anyone who has worked with data knows
this cleaning data it's like so much the
battle you get like this this massive
great big wallop of data you're like
brilliant that's gonna be so good I
can't wait to like dive in and then you
realize just how long it takes to make
it that to get it into a shape where it
work or it does anything that you want
it to do we think an example of
something that can give you I can tell
you in my field we just call it reducing
the data if I showed you raw data from
the universe you say what the hell is
that where's my pretty Hubble picture
well if you knew what the hell happened
between the photon hitting the telescope
and the photo that ended up in the press
you'd be you might be shocked but no you
wouldn't be honey but others might so
you have an example they must be one
that's really funny and quite stupid
well they might come out in the Q&A part
so we can okay that's the one we want
definitely I know you definitely want
one ways that way somebody's just really
stupid
another quick thing about your bio tell
me about you're at BBC four radio show
oh okay so this is a show that I host
with the geneticist Adam Rutherford and
we've been going for about I think we're
nice we're recording our 16th series now
so the idea is that people send us in
questions and we go out and investigate
them and initially we because radio 4 is
like
it's kind of the posh channel that's
very highbrow it's very there's no music
it's all it's where the politicians go
it's where they have like these deep
intellectual debates I mean they have
like you know programs on philosophy on
it right it's at least the very kind of
like the very highbrow stuff so
initially we wanted our program to be
very high grantee and to be very serious
and like with very serious scientists
what we discovered quite quickly that
actually what works better is if you
just basically muck around and as a
result of that the questions that have
been coming in have been from families
with younger kids and they end up being
like the best questions so we had a
question that I really liked which was
what's the tiniest dinosaur right which
is a question that was asked of us by
like an eight-year-old seems like a
really you know trivial silly question
that you can just dismiss with the with
a quick Google search but actually
unfold this whole thing of like how do
you define size how do you define
dinosaur you know this whole kind of
world underneath it so yeah that's
really what it's morphed into is just
this
yeah like wonderful playground where all
the annoying questions that kids want to
ask their parents they send them in to
us to the benefit I think of the
listeners so it kind of under some of
their pasha tude is that it does it's
definitely not pop let's see if we can
lead off with a question here Chuck we
got a first question on algorithms and
data for one of the worlds yeah yeah so
don't search then let's go let's start
off we always start off with a patreon
patron because they give us money so
let's go to t TJ Monroe from patreon
says dr. Tyson and dr. Fry the two bets
radio voices in science oh well wait so
how is Rutherford's voice in your show
is it okay we got two hours show that
all right
yeah he says can you walk through the
process of creating a predictive
algorithm for something like the path of
a lightning bolt or lotion currents now
one is a lot easier than the other yes
what one repeat one repeats itself you
say that Chuck is you're an expert on
this well yes so Neil in my in my spare
time what I'd like that's a great
question what I like about it is if
there are two things that are highly
sort of you know oceans can be turbulent
you have storms and things but there's
is a prevailing thing you know where
lightnings gonna strike but you know
it's gonna strike somewhere over there
so I love that question so Hanna has
that reduced itself to algorithms at
this point or not so I haven't seen an
algorithm for for predicting lightning
strikes but I want I'm just thinking
through how you could do it so certainly
there are gonna be certain things that
that go into it as you say right like
there are certain days when you can look
out in the sky and be pretty confident
that no lightning strikes are gonna
happen in other days where you can be
fairly confident that they will there's
certain things that you can measure in
the atmosphere the atmospheric pressure
the humidity all of those kind of things
that you could plug into a system that
could help you predict the likelihood of
a lightning strike but the exact path of
it I mean know you probably know more
about this than me but I would say that
the exact part of it is gonna be very
difficult to deduce would you call it an
algorithm if you are checking the the
atmospheric pressure and the humidity
and the size of the clouds and the
moisture if those are just inputs to
something that calculates does that come
under your category of algorithm as well
yeah I think same I think so I mean
obviously there are different kinds of
algorithm and you know the artificial
intelligence is one that gets a lot of
attention and the algorithms that deal
with sort of data on the Internet is
another I think that anything is taking
taking something from the real world
like a recipe right like taking
ingredients from the real world doing
something with it and then spitting out
some kind of answer I think for me that
counts as an algorithm you know when you
technically if you stop an on someone
for directions you're in your car and
you step in on someone for directions
and they say go down
that way that way that way I mean
technically they're giving you an
algorithm right right so okay so so
Malcolm is a very wide catch basin then
for accounting for things that you want
to predict or understand so with with
lightning
you'll only discharge a cloud if there's
a if the build up in charge is very
different either from one cloud to
another cloud or between the cloud and
the ground and so like you said and if
you measure the humidity you can check
to see what is the propensity of
electricity and across a humid air
versus dry hair and look at a threshold
for that and you say when hits this
threshold it's going and how much of
algorithms is also threshold enamelling
Oh Lots nice so I think yeah and I think
that that's the difference between and
sometimes you are trying to predict
exactly what's gonna happen you know
you're gonna you're trying to predict
let's say you know from all is rolling
down a hill or whatever like exactly
where it's gonna end up that kind of
thing and sometimes you're just saying
as you said like what is the probability
that this might happen and at what point
do you set this threshold to say okay my
friend says yeah this the example that I
gave you earlier about the Fennell thing
right it's like it's not definitely you
know it's not like you buy phenol
therefore you're not going to claim on
your home insurance it's like you buy
you buy phenol therefore you're likely
to be a home cook therefore you're
likely to do isn't it and then you sort
of all the way through those you're
going to be setting thresholds where you
say if it tips over this then you know
we assume you're a home cook if it tips
over this we assume or you know whatever
interesting okay so that's an important
fact here because it's not the one piece
of data that tells you what everything
is it's the one piece of data that might
put you over the over the edge of that
conclusion I think well you know when
you're dealing with uncertainty I mean
very there are very few things
especially when you're when you're you
know handling data to do with human
behavior very few things are cold hard
facts right very few things are you're
rarely dealing in absolutes so when
you're handling uncertainty the only way
that you can possibly
convert uncertainty into a yes/no answer
is by saying here's the line if we cross
it we'll assume as a yes and the ocean
currents those like you said Chuck those
have prevailing they're not catastrophic
the way a lightning bolt is so
presumably that doesn't have this kind
of threshold antara there are you know
much they're sort of very sophisticated
equations that can describe fluid flow
right so they're still not absolute you
know especially when you're dealing with
turbulence there's still a lot of
probability and randomness and chaos
right that's involved in all of that but
you can say with more it's it's it's not
a threshold in problem your as you say
right you're like you can say with more
certainty where things are gonna be
there's also connection when you're
dealing with ocean currents as opposed
to lightning bolts ocean currents are
all connected because it's not one ocean
it's an entire oceanic system that
happens on the globe
whereas lightning bolts are isolated
incidents so that's that there's that
too I mean they assume it's
two-dimensional
[Laughter]
yeah Chuck that you start subtracting
dimensions to make the problem easier to
solve whether or not your answer is
correct to that we have take a first
let's take our first break and when we
come back more cosmic queries with data
mathematician Hanna Frey when we return
Startalk cosmic queries algorithms and
data yeah I said it
algorithms
Chuck nice those tweeting at Chuck nice
comic Thank You Sara and we have as our
special guest professor of mathematics
at University College London Hanna Frey
Hanna
minused a professor you just gave me a
motion man thank you I will do that you
take you take that to the bank and to
your yeah well that's your department
chair Hanna Hanna how would you like to
be a Chancellor I want to be so so Chuck
you got another question about Davis all
right sure sure sure
let's um let's go back to patreon and
let's go to Shawshank submarine Ian who
says Neil hello and Hannah hello I would
like to know how impactful would solving
the P versus non P problem with respect
to our capabilities of understanding the
universe
excuse me the P versus non P problem is
we all fluent and yes exactly
if you if you have consumed copious
amounts of liquid what is your proximity
to your water closet so Hannah with what
is P versus non PN is that a real
outstanding problem in math yeah yeah
exactly so and this is one of the
Millennium math problems so if you solve
this chunk was named shanks submarine
Ian was showing off by the way with this
question he's showing off if you solve
this problem you win a million dollars
so I mean it's kind of maybe the the
change is the university bigger but
definitely Chancellor um okay so let's
say that I gave you a gigantic Sudoku
puzzle and asked you to solve it I mean
I like a really massive one why not just
like nine nine to get and a massive
massive one and a source of it would
take you forever to solve it but if I
said
here's the solved one I want you to
check if it's right actually that's a
much easier problem right and even
though they could be the same Sudoku
puzzle finding it in in the first place
is much much much harder than just
checking minutes right so where would
you say a solved puzzle there would be
why it's right so you mean a filled-in
puzzle okay yeah you're right my
language is sloughing I take it back
okay
so sometimes where you've got like a
blank Sudoku grid effectively you know
or the analogy in in computers if it's
very easy to check that the answers
right sometimes you can use that as a
loophole to get you to the answer very
quickly right because you can just
generate answers and check if they're
right rather than kind of go through and
grunt through the entire process um so
the question is is that always the case
if you can check that an answer is right
quickly much quicker than you can to
solve the problem in the first place
um is that always the case can you solve
something do really hard problems that
you've got to grunt through always have
quick solutions or not and the the
reason why this has repercussions and
the reason why this has you know
potential impact on that understanding
of the universe is that an awful lot of
the algorithms that we use to try and
understand gigantic systems you know I'm
sure that this is certainly true in a
lot of cosmology a lot of them have to
use very clever workarounds to to
account for the fact that some problems
are just really hard some problems you
kind of have to grunt through and to
find the answer so there are a whole
host of different algorithms that exist
try and make that that you know that
grunting process easier but if it were
the case that actually all these
difficult problems do have an easy quick
solution I mean that would be if you you
know if you could suddenly reduce the
amount of computational time that you
spend on the problem I mean that would
have a dramatic dramatic effect on the
number of things that you could compute
so I want to chuck on this show off in
front of Hannah so give me a moment here
a lot of D think so did the for color
map plan
yeah I was around and in college when
that was solved and it was considered
inelegant because someone put an
algorithm and just grunted through it
and but they solved it and no one else
had solved it before
so in principle then that implies that
it was easier to solve it that way than
by any analytic way that a fair analogy
here or not ah yeah I mean that one
people got very upset about that yes I
remember that yeah that like because
normally when you do a proof you write
it down and this is this this elegant
statements of logic it fits on the back
of an envelope yeah exactly at the risk
of not being a part of the for color map
3 the 4 color map for a lovefest what
what the hell is the 4 color map problem
okay you know when you get like a map of
the states you know there are seeds and
you've got like all of the different
states whatever and you want to color it
in yeah the question is can you color in
with four colors so that no two states
next to each other share the same color
right turns out that you can the
question is is there so the the full
color problem is let me get this right
now so you know you might remember more
than me but is it does any map exist for
which you cannot economy in in full
context that's the way number of
comments that you need to call her any
map I think we knew that the four colors
was the right answer we just didn't have
a proof of it and so it was it was
intractable until somebody again I went
to college so long ago computers were
new to the world of math punch cards
only I mean it was the seventies right
there was the seventies yes it was back
when I was in college I'm like a
steam-powered hazard so and it was
proven but only through this by checking
the answer not by proving the answer
that it feels like what you just
described
and so I give an example from my field I
think and I think this is an example we
have people looking for galaxies that
are very very low in their surface
brightness like you would you would scan
by it you wouldn't even know it was
there
well how do how do you look for them if
they don't reveal themselves well we the
ones we have found we know what their
light profile looks like and so what we
can do is set up a filter that goes out
and tries to match the light in the sky
to that filter and when you get a slight
increase in a match there's a galaxy now
you can put all your resources there say
yep there's a galaxy there so actually
so you you're looking for the answer to
ask the question yes yes yes yes Hannah
is this legit I mean are we allowed to
do I mean that's that's it I mean these
are great examples of like grunting
through the solution and the question is
is that always the easiest way or is
there actually a trick is there some
clever trick that you could have used
you know I don't know like folding your
data in half and looking for like there
and this superimpose like lights you
know and maybe there's some clever trick
somewhere that this there's no one
spotted yet you know there's so often
cases where people come up with these
clever tricks and maybe there was a
clever trick that the whole thing could
have been sold much quicker we're not
having to grant it three okay so if this
problem gets solved then it'll give us
confidence for all future prop
problems to say don't even worry about
figuring out the answer analytically
let's just compute the answer and then
check it yeah I mean if that's easier
then that for me that's less romantic
that's less elegant but if it were at
the same time you have to think of the
potential repercussions of this like you
know there are some problems like if you
take protein folding as an example right
so um proteins are just the source of of
so much you know of life I mean
essentially they're like the fundamental
building blocks of building blocks
everything that could happen to the
human body from you know outsiders to
the drugs that you like the effective
drugs that you take I mean everything it
all comes down to proteins and proteins
then
like these long ribbons of amino acids
and the way that they fold up determines
their function these things are
incredibly incredibly incredibly
complicated and it's okay to go from the
bolded up the folder that bundle of
ribbon to the long string is possible
but going from the long string to work
out what folded up knotted shape it
makes is really really really really
super super super hard we understand all
of the physics of it we have you know
equations that could work it out but you
just cannot grunt through it all and if
you let's say that you could solve this
problem let's say that you could have a
computer that could grunt through all
the possibilities what that would mean
is you could say I want a protein that
serves this function I want a protein
that can combat this disease I want a
protein that acts on the body in this
way what shape is it you know it's like
this shape okay now what is the string
of amino acids I need to print to create
that protein I mean I'm talking like
long long long long long term here these
are not like things that are round the
corner but I mean however I think there
are some applications of this stuff that
means that actually romance that you
know romance is dead romance when you've
got protein for business so chuck is
listening attentively here cuz he wants
to know the formula for a funny joke I
really don't why would I change anything
now how do you fold your words together
to guarantee there's a funny joke well
done and I'm sure there's an algorithm
for that you know and believe me I would
love that and it's funny because it
sounds like what you're talking about is
quantum computing it's extreme level of
it yeah you could get the computing
power and then all problems will just be
solved with depending on whoever spends
time looking at it that that like I have
to reiterate Hannah that would take away
the romance of the quest for me a little
bit I think a little bit you have to
sigh did you head outside yeah that was
yes what you say do you think that do
you think the full kata program was
unromantic
yes yes yeah yeah I mean I
because you know we have D equals MC
square that fits you know children write
down that equation is one of the most
profound equations in the universe how
many forces are there in the universe
there's not thousands there's four all
right and there in the early universe
there was fewer you want I have a bias a
philosophical bias that I when I park
the curtains I want to find simplicity
rather than complexity do you think the
simplicity always exists though or do
you think actually sometimes in here
physicists you can get like drawn into
this sort of I don't know it's like it's
like a potion of simplicity so here's a
here's my lesson that I have to tell
myself to get out of this sort of state
of romance Johannes Kepler when he first
showed the the the planets going around
the Sun and he was trying to figure out
what kind of orbits did they have and
about their distances and he had a
system where he he's a mathematician and
you know they're the five platonic
solids do you know about this check the
five solids it's a singing group from
sixteen that's what I was looking for
that's exactly what I was so how do you
want to tell him the 5 solids before I
come to me Plato was like super into
this idea of everything being perfect
so the Platonic solids are the five
shapes that can be created where every
side of the ship is the same so cube is
a platonic solid every side is square
tetrahedron octahedron and the
icosahedron and I think you left out the
the piraha which is whether the
four-sided pyramid are identical
tetrahedron no she said it oh you said
okay yes she said tetrahedron do we get
fives so tetrahedron octahedron a
dodecahedron
so each of those have 1/2 of the same
shape polygons on all sides but they're
only five of them so Kepler knew this
and he also knew that they were
six planets and he said well everything
is perfect in Devine and math is perfect
maybe the planets are the separations
occupy orbits in the separations between
nested platonic solids so he he took
them and nested them and put planet
orbits and he actually got pretty close
it was like but this was his ideal this
was his sense of perfection that he was
imposing on nature and was all [ __ ]
no I think I think I think it does
happen where people fall in love with
the simplicity of their theory and
forget that actually often the worlds
really ugly yes yes I used the Kepler
example we had to his credit it took him
15 years but to his credit not ten years
but he discarded the entire system and
out came elliptical orbits which all
beats fall that's beautiful it's perfect
circles as Copernicus had presumed but
said let's go to the next question Chuck
all right let's go to John Baker from
patreon he says hi guys I'm back to
prove my ignorance yet again what kind
of empirical data is used well first let
me ask a core question what does it mean
to use an algorithm not that I couldn't
look it up on wiki or or I could have
just paid attention in school I love
John Baker this guy's amazing anyway and
you know what I should I should have let
off with this question I but because the
truth is what we never have touched upon
in this show yet what is an algorithm
101 give it to me
okay 101 algorithm is this gigantic
umbrella term that doesn't really mean
very much which i think is the reason
why people hate the word so much but
essentially all it is is a series of
logical steps that take you from some
input to some kind of output right so a
recipe a cake recipe that counts as an
algorithm your inputs in your
the logical steps is the recipe itself
that outputs the cake that you get at
the end the difference though isn't it
wait a cake recipe is a flowchart I
would think there's a flowchart
inaudible yeah it's just like a giant
like algorithm the word Akron just is
like this giant all-encompassing term
but I think when people use it they tend
to mean something within a computer say
something we're inputting some data and
then the machine has some kind of
autonomy in terms of the decisions that
it makes along the way and spits out an
answer at the end so computer programs
you do in a program is an algorithm you
know like 80 years old in my video on my
screen I know my Zedeck spectrum is kind
of the British equivalent you would do
like print hello go to line 10 and then
it just goes by round around around and
just be like the whole fill the whole
screen with the light right that was the
kind of programming that everyone did
for them like kids and technically
that's an algorithm is just a really
rubbish Natsuki not really doing
anything so I think people use the word
they tend to mean it they tend to mean
it it's like some kind of automated
decision-making that's sort of really
what they mean but I but I think you
know we're being absolutely fair there
algorithm encompasses all of this now
Chuck the person had more to that
question but we just ran out of time in
this segment so when we come back we'll
pick up more on the angst shared by this
questioner who wondered whether he
should have learned all this in school
in the first place this is Startalk
cosmic queries we'll be right back
Startalk we're back cosmic queries
algorithms and data edition you never
thought we'd go there but we did so
there
I got chuck of course and a professor
Hanna Frey associate professor of
mathematics at University College London
you shared with us earlier in the
session that you live in Greenwich and
we've all heard of granite even if
you've never been there Greenwich Time
and that's like the time the the base
time of the world right you get kind of
cocky about that it's you know how she
took me to move to Greenwich have any
litter for three years I say but it took
me to move to Greenwich to realize that
Greenwich Mean Time is the word meaning
it actually means average mean across an
entire year I didn't know that oh yeah
pretty tirely of course 24 hours a day
is 24 hours this night it's 24 hours on
average yeah yeah the time it takes this
the time it takes the Sun to return to
its spot on the sky on average is 24
hours sometimes it takes longer
sometimes it tastes less people don't
know that yeah yeah I was happily
drinking my Greenwich Mean Time lager
Greenwich Mean Time village and I didn't
realize that mean men average mean yeah
it has nothing to do with the emotional
state of your time zone so Chuck we left
off someone upset that he didn't learn
the meaning of algorithm in school but I
think there's a question he said what
does it mean to use and algorithms and
then Hahn and I said like oh well a
recipe is an algorithm like I like what
had I like the distinction and is making
as we go forward in the 21st century
that we've
think of algorithms as an automated
procedure rather you don't thing that
you do something it makes decision and
then I think there's a fabless
distinction there as well between an
algorithm and artificial intelligence
and I think that like the way I like to
think of this is let's say you've got a
smart light bulb that's kind of
connected to the internet and you decide
to program it so that it turns on at 6
o'clock and goes off at 11 o'clock
so that's an algorithm right you've
programmed it you said if it's 6 o'clock
turn off right if it'll turn on whether
that's it's just a straightforward
algorithm if it was artificial
intelligence generally speaking most
people agree that artificial
intelligence needs to include some
aspect of learning so instead the light
bulb would recognize that you came home
at 6 o'clock and turned the light on it
would recognize that you liked to dim
the switch you know 9 p.m. when you do
some reading and then you go to bed at
11 o'clock so if it started to learn
from its environment and then impose
those walls itself that counts as
artificial intelligence and but but but
that's simply an updatable algorithm
yeah yeah exactly it's something that's
continually revising in addition to that
though it is also more importantly
pattern recognition so the update is
based on the recognition of patterns
technically agree yeah completely
which is odd until very recently now
Hannah you scared me a little when you
began that comment because you said
imagine a smart light bulb and I thought
aren't smart robots enough what would a
smart light bulb marching down the
street I love the smart lightbulbs
humans must die in order for us to shine
humans must die exactly and in fact they
would they would dig up the joke from
there's a comedian whose Twitter handle
is the science comedian and I quote him
every now and then one of my one of my
favorite jokes of his what comments was
the light bulb was such a good idea it
became a symbol for a good idea as honey
that's
so if light bulbs become our overlords
they will remind us that any time we
think something brilliant it's one of
them that exactly right
don't think we don't know what you're
thinking well we only know what you're
thinking if it's a good thing if it's a
good thought we know it okay all right
that's funny
so the sights to meet is Brian Mel if
anybody want to dig about okay so you
got another question there check short
thing this has been sellers and Ben
wants to know this from an evolution
standpoint our relationships and mating
behaviors probably follow patterns
useful for hunter-gatherers how do our
behaviors on social media and dating
websites resemble patterns from more
primitive days what would make
interacting online more connected to our
primitive programming now I don't know
if this is your purview Hannah but he's
he's making a really you know pretty
pretty poignant Association which is we
now find people online that's how we
find love now I mean and and the number
is only going up every year do the
hunter-gatherer you know brain sets
actually apply to the way that we go
after one another digitally it's like
I'm just foraging foraging for lovers
hunter-gatherers yeah and by the way
this kind of a foraging swipe right
swipe right so actually one of the very
first things I did as soon as I finished
my PhD was I did this really silly talk
that was like actually supposed to be
this kind of private joke that just got
really out of hands which was called the
mat of love right which was in part
looking at data or from online dating
websites and I it was kind of this thing
where I just wanted to demonstrate that
you can take a mathematical view to
everything anyway it got terribly out of
hand and ended up being a TED talk and
and but in that there was something that
was really interesting I think it's
relevant to this which is no wait just
just a quick thing Anna
most people who have thoughts that get
out of hand don't end up giving TED
talks
so it requires some level of brilliance
to distinguish you from everybody else
for a number of years in Britain people
started calling me dr. love and I was
like it was just a joke guys there's
never been serious I'm really not dr.
love anyway um okay so in in it one of
the things that I talked about was about
who gets most attention right whose
photos get most attention on dating
websites and you would think okay surely
it's gonna be the people who everyone
considers is best-looking right I mean
surely right the most attractive people
get the most centage really but um so
OkCupid kind of an interesting dating
website because for a while there they
were totally open about the fact that
they were experimenting on their
customers and like release or their data
and also on their website what you're
allowed to do was rate how attractive
you thought other people were on a scale
between one and five right so finds very
beautiful one I think slightly more
facially challenged as the technical
term and what happens then what they
found was that it's not true that just
the people who get finds get the most
attention it was the people who divided
opinion the most so the people who were
getting the most attention were like
averaging out as kind of a four but they
weren't people where everyone was giving
them a four there were people where some
people would give them five and lots of
people would give him a one some people
thought they were absolutely horrific
and some people thought they're really
beautiful and the explanation for this
which I quite like
is kind of like an instinctive one so I
guess this sort of goes into the
hunter-gatherer thing in a way which is
that it's like a game theory thing right
if you are if you come across someone
and you think that they're very
beautiful
then you imagine they're getting lots of
attention and you think well why would I
there's no point in throwing my hat in
that ring I may as well stand back
whereas if you come across someone who
you think is very beautiful but you
imagine other people will really dislike
so something that someone who's a bit
unusual in some way then you're like
great this gorgeous person isn't gonna
be getting much attention then you kind
of like throw throw yourself in but
because everyone's doing that that means
it's the really beautiful people who are
not getting any attention in the kind of
quirky once again not so so what you're
saying
apart from the the socio-cultural
lessons from that is algorithms that
might apply to human behavior that data
that we're now collecting on billions of
people provide might have some strong
evolutionary guidance for us going
forward yeah I mean I think it's always
like tough didn't leave me back the
evolution isn't it but I do think that
that you can you can certainly come up
with these game theoretic arguments for
the patterns in our behavior I mean you
know they're not exactly falsifiable but
um but I think there's there's a fun to
explore but it means you have an
algorithm that applies that that's
established in one environment like
Chuck was saying you're on the you're on
the plains of the Serengeti there's a
certain algorithm for our behavior that
we can't shake because it's genetically
encoded within us perhaps yeah I mean
perhaps yeah I mean I guess I'm sure
there's like antibodies who know this
much better than me but yeah and like I
don't doubt it I'm sure that there there
are lots of occasions where we actually
instinctively where you know our ancient
our ancient history causes us to act in
a certain way and I'm sure that we do it
still even when we are interacting with
people on a completely different
platform to the one that we were
designed for so Chuck we got effort
maybe one or two more questions
Wow all right God well we're gonna have
to do another show man I have eleven
pages that is how many people are really
like interested in this subject it's
unbelievable thank you an algorithm sir
I know we're wrapping it up so I'm
trying to find one okay here's one
okay this is Dean from Twitter and Dean
said wait Chuck you're just choosing
people whose names you can pronounce
this whole episode have been
pronounceable names hi let me go with
them instead I'll go with TLO Jungmann
us
okay that's better Dean oh yeah this
moment and sorry we're gonna do the show
again so we'll get that deep all right
so this is yellow Jungmann young man's
junk mountains okay okay he says he says
assume that the game on behavioral data
is already over the next level is
biological data and the one after that
is thought police okay um what are your
expiration expectations and what do you
think the outcomes will be so what he's
really talking about there is predictive
analytics when we ever get predictive
analytics to a point where you have
pre-crime like oh you didn't commit a
crime but you know what we know you're
gonna commit this crime because these
algorithms have actually profiled you in
such a way that tells us that you are a
criminal
Hannah you said that about about fennel
okay oh you did if you know that much
about who a person is if they buy fennel
mmm I love what checks Chuck said there
can can you get our the algorithm is so
good that they know your thoughts and
then they know your next behavior and
they you pre arrest someone okay so this
is such a this is such a tough topic
right like I spent huge chunk of my good
talking about this um you know
predictive policing and predictive
algorithms in the name of your book
again just so we get good hello world
hello well hello world life in the age
of I can't remember they gave us in
America I think it's has to be human in
the age of the algorithm maybe that's
we're gonna say I can't remember what
the name of my book title is different
America yeah they do that sometimes yeah
okay
let the translate between two
english-speaking countries have to
translate okay
um okay so right this is like a really
tough topic because the thing is is that
some people have definitely tried to do
this they have definitely been some
situations in which people have tried to
predict so there was one particular
example in Chicago I think it was where
they the idea was quite straightforward
right which was like okay well when it
comes to gun crime often tomorrow's
today's victims are tomorrow's
perpetrators so if you analyze the
network of people who you know who
people are friends with you know you
people hang out with that kind of stuff
if you analyze that network and see and
feed in where events are happening can
you come up with like a risk score if
you like this is kind of like your the
threshold thing that you were talking
about earlier with with with lightning
can you come up with a risk score that
says we think that that this group of
people or this group of people are
likely to be involved in something in
the near future and when this whole
system was set up it was set up in kind
of a nice way like I think it was set up
with good intentions because the idea
was that if your name appeared on this
list um then police and social workers
social workers yes yes precisely and
we've come out to your house and they
would so it would be like intervention
in the intervention right but it's like
you know here are these programs that
you can join here are these alternatives
that you can you know want to help you
out of this life that you're in right
that was kind of like the intention of
course of course it didn't work out that
way because if you give that list to
people we've got completely different
set of priorities as soon as there was
you know gun homicide it turned out that
people took this listen start at the top
of the list and then just started
arresting all the way down so by the end
you RAND Corporation did this analysis
of the whole project and by the end the
people who were on the list were
remember the numbers but basically way
more times way more likely to have been
arrested by the police
regardless of whether they were involved
in the original crime so essentially it
turned into a list a harassment list
right and I think this is thing I think
that in it in like a lab setting in kind
of a cop the cold like environment
an ivory tower actually I think there
are certain things that you can say
about like likelihood you know like
there are there are some people that you
can pick out who you know in a million
years they're never going to commit a
gun homicide and then there are other
people who you know perhaps aren't quite
in the same boat and I think there are
some things that you could say about
humans but the problem is is that the
world isn't this ivory tower
you can't like create a system that
gives you that information because it
doesn't then tell you what you're
supposed to do with it it doesn't tell
you how you're supposed to interact with
people it doesn't tell you what you're
supposed to do with it and I think that
I haven't yet heard of a really positive
story where people have tried to do
something like that and it's gone really
well because I just think it's just I
just think like interact that kind of
yeah the real world is messy the real
world is missing right so and I think
just a I will figure out what to do with
the data hey I will know to become our
overlords and subjugate us because we
can't take care of ourselves definitely
why I mean also right I thought was that
there was a point like a couple of years
ago where everyone
I mean genuinely newspaper articles had
that attitude of like oh just feed it
into the AI and it will be able to
predict everything and this so this book
actually this one here let's go here max
out Nick he did this amazing project
where he had our memories on how many
bits thousands of kids write thousands
of kids and he had data on them from
when they were when they were born when
there were five years old ten years and
old all the way up into the teens and he
had everything on them right he had you
know what their parents did he had
entities with them and I unimaginable
that big big big data right on these
kids and what he did very cleverly is he
released the data you know to the public
anonymized and so on in stages and he
held back the last stage when they were
I think 18 and he asked people all
around the world he said here's
everything you know about these kids
from naught 15 I want you to predict how
many of them ended up in trouble how
many of them went on to further
education all of those different configs
and everyone around the world with their
very clever AI and they're very clever
all of this that in the other tried to
do it
would you like to know what came out on
top linear regression Oh basic the most
basic basic basic what's gone before
will cut well it won't happen again
again
you fit a line to the trend in the data
yeah there you have it yeah that sucked
in case you didn't know that linear
regression is the that's fitting a line
through the data they have to put more
syllables to that right yeah it's just
drawing a line on a graph I think you've
got that right guys by the way I would
probably fact-check about slightly
because it might have been whatever I
may have got a tiny couple of those
facts wrong yeah we don't care it's a
great story I'm sticking with that so we
got to bring this to a close but we have
to have Hannah back on oh my gosh we've
only just scratched the surface
especially with eleven pages and it
clearly you've triggered interest in our
fan base and they're gonna want more of
you as we go forward but I think correct
me if I'm wrong Hannah that one of the
great lessons of this is really maybe
everyone should have paid attention in
their math class because math will be
math will be the foundational forces
that define our social cultural
existence in this world did I overstate
that Hannah or not yeah no I think
that's actually I always think like if I
think that it's really hard to realize
how important this stuff is because it's
invisible and I kind of think you know
it drones like drones came along and
then all of a sudden they were loads of
drones everywhere and everyone got
really upset and now you've gotta have
every license possible to fly a drone I
always think that like if you could see
algorithms in the same way that you
could see drones I think people would be
a lot more you know willing to well on
it really I think that they'd want to
educate themselves a lot more about it
so yeah they'd just be really annoyed by
how the rhythms like they are drunk so
okay guys we got it we got to wrap this
up Hannah thank you very much for
sharing your wisdom your insights and
some of it pleasing some of it scary
part of what we need going forward Chuck
always good
I like the pleasure this has been a
cosmic queries edition on data and
algorithms I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist leading you as
always
[Music]